[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
ich mache heute ein perfektes dinner
okay ich versuche zumindest für den jura
und die challenge dabei ist dass ich
nicht weiß mit welchen produkten
[Musik]
als er gleichzeitig habe die reine hölle
box und zwar wäre schon bei mir auf der
messe war dieses jahr oder auch im shop
bestellt hat der kennt wahrscheinlich
schon brennt news wer haltlos das ist
'ne box da gibt es ganz viele
verschiedene bei uns im shop gab es als
mini box als kleines geschenk für euch
und jetzt haben wir mit brennt uns
zusammen eine zelle buchs gemacht auf
die idee es immer übrigens gekommen weil
bei uns ist es so wenn murat und nicht
am wochenende einkaufen mittlerweile
geht aber ist alleine einkaufen aber
meistens mit der familie zusammen und
dann also zu 80 prozent kaufte mir
eigentlich immer das gleiche ich glaube
jeder kennt zu sein und supermarkt weg
man kauft immer die gleichen produkte
und oft will es einem schwer was neues
auszuprobieren und wir haben sind
irgendwann beschlossen com in dem jedes
mal ein neues produkt mit jeder darf
einmal eins aussuchen und so sind wir
einfach immer auf der suche nach etwas
neuem entdecken mal ist das plus x ist
das was wir sagen okay braucht man immer
wieder
webradios ist es im prinzip das gleiche
also man kann da entweder ein abo machen
oder auch einmalig einfach nur
ausprobieren und dann bekommt man eine
box zugeschickt man weiß aber nicht was
drin steckt und dann bekommt man das
päckchen zugeschickt und da ist halt
immer mehr halt immer neue produkte drin
start ups zum beispiel oder auch von
größeren marken neue produkte die noch
nicht im handel sind zum ausprobieren
und die kann man echt ganz toll
ausprobieren interviews gibt es übrigens
auch im gesicht und zwar ist es der
daniele der daniel ist ein freund von
uns aus hamburg dessen papa übrigens den
weltbesten italiener hat dort muss ich
mal gesagt haben und beim daniela maus
im prinzip genauso wie bei uns er dann
auch sagt die neuesten produkte die im
handel landen oftmals probiert man die
gar nicht aus und wenn man von 100
produkten drei produkte sind die regale
schaffen sondern ist echt schon gut und
das meiste wird einfach nicht gekauft
weil es einfach keiner kennt und keiner
ausprobiert und er hat sich zur aufgabe
gemacht das zu unterstützen die in die
box mit rein zu packen und die somit
einfach ein bisschen publik zu machen
und so kann man einfach jeden monat neue
produkte ausprobieren
finde ich richtig cool und jetzt haben
wir zusammen die sally box gemacht und
das ist jetzt auch eine premiere also
fallen heute premiere denn hier ist die
erste box in der kühl produkte sind aber
auch trockene produkte und hier habe ich
jetzt die box ich weiß nicht was drin
steckt ich habe dem nichts gekommen ich
mache zum menü
aus diesen produkten und ich überlege
mir hier so live murat muss später
probiert und darf dann alles verkosten
und bewerten
ich hoffe es schmeckt gut ok ich glaube
ich mache jetzt erstmal alles für euch
auf
[Musik]
okay hier sind die 17 produkte und ich
muss sagen es wird eine schwierige
aufgabe hier rezepte zu kreieren vor
allem weil ich ja alle sitze im produkte
in einem drei gänge menü verwenden
möchte also präsentieren wir mal die
vorspeise wir machen jetzt aus
blätterteig kleine häppchen
da kommt der käse drauf mit kräuterquark
das machen wir hier drauf würzt das
ganze mit salz und pfeffer
dann haben wir tomaten in scheiben oben
drauf und dann haben uns überlegt weil
wir von heute morgen noch eier haben
hartgekochte eier gibt es noch immer
salat den peppen wird dann auf mit
paprika gurke machen einen senf dressing
und ich glaube es wird ziemlich fulda
den mango joghurt dazu nehmen wir haben
also ein bisschen das süße dabei und
wird sind das noch ein bisschen mit
essig
ich finde aber ganz cool wenn man
produkte nimmt und einfach
zweckentfremden das also den joghurt
kann man sowohl der schmeckt das große
palette kannst du dir dann könnte ich
schon mal das dressing verrühren okay
also dressing frankfurt etwas fühlt
wenn es passt immer gut zu 1 was ist das
mittel bekannt
ok
[Musik]
da ein bisschen pfeffer mein papa
gefällt unser rezept
[Musik]
mal gucken schmeckt folgt mit speck so
gut mit dem mango joghurt dressing ist
bereit und ich hab dir zum schneiden ok
und die art die kannst du gleich
schneiden
ach so dass man immer gleich mit rein
okay es ist amira schild und schneidet
die eier in würfel und ich schneide die
fabrik ein würfel von den backofen habe
vorgeheizt
[Musik]
herzlich gurken und paprika kann ich
jetzt schon mal zum dressing dazugeben
und du schneidest grad noch die eier und
ich nehme jetzt hier noch den käse den
scheiben käse und den schneide ich jetzt
auch einfach in streifen
[Musik]
also sobald du die rein und fertig
geschrieben hat darf sich hier eingeben
ok und dann einfach umrühren und dann
probieren was mann und ich kann hier
schon mal saubermachen und dann machen
wir nämlich die blätterteig
[Musik]
ich nehme erst mal den blätterteig ich
habe zwar nicht drauf geguckt aber hier
nicht gleich gesehen dass noch runde
schon hätte auch eine tat machen kann
aber wir wollen ja wir machen ja kleine
häppchen als vorspeise also ist so gut
ich werde das jetzt einfach so schneiden
und dann haben wir kleine hörnchen cool
oder unternehmen wir jetzt den cremigen
weichkäse
er bringt ihn wirksam das gericht ist
die krise mit gut geld habe ich bisher
auch auf deinem schneidebrett plus x zu
dir über
[Musik]
ich bin glaube ich darf doch für die
hauptspeise machen wir mit vielen tipps
wie camembert krems camberg kenne ich
eigentlich nur dann kann man bei am
stück und ich haben eine creme maximal
probieren
[Musik]
ja manchmal hatten die aussagen daran
gebe da solltet würfelt war die macht
sich halt nicht ob das hier wird es
ziemlich cool bei der firma jetzt die
tomaten draufmachen und gewürze
[Musik]
top ist gut was an ihrer kannst du dann
die tomaten drauflegen
ich mache geführte drauf ich ein
bisschen auch da
[Musik]
b
ich weiß natürlich das gericht wird und
die da aber gross hier in ihrem kleinere
und dann wollen wir die herren schon
einfach auf
[Musik]
so und dann vorsichtig auf rollen und
zwar rolle ich jetzt die hörnchen so auf
dass die ränder offen bleiben
ich glaube dann verteilt sich der käse
auch ein bisschen schön drin und
eigentlich wollte ich den riesterfaktor
eingeben
aber ich glaube es wird so viel den
immer daran stirbt
[Musik]
so sagen wir chelsea fällt mir richtig
gut
damit die hörnchen auch schöne farbe
kriegen bestreichen sie jetzt noch mit
eigelb und dann schon im backofen
[Musik]
vorspeise durchsackt
anrichten einer salat
die katag war
manchmal so als tipp dazu
[Musik]
so kriegt das jetzt also morath erster
gang
die vorspeise ich glaube wenn man das
aus einem großen teller anrichten sieht
cool aus
also du sagst es vorgaben zu klären und
ich brüte mal was es ist und ich sagte
was es ist das ist ein alter habe ich
recht cool dass paprikas fünf richtig
sind guten dass irgendwas anderes
natürlich drin
[Musik]
ich komme schon mango nein mama
joghurtdressing ehrlich jetzt
warum also nicht so sehr ein salat mich
so so penetrant nach und schmeckt er ist
und nicht so schwer genau und die
meisten machen ja er hat mit mayonnaise
und genau ja genau und es ist ja mango
hat
[Musik]
wie komme ich auf die idee manko guten
zusammen zu tun und ich wollte halt denn
unterstützen nicht nur so angeblich
mitte laster hat bleibt drin sein
ich liebte teig mit mach ich das mit so
genial richtig heiß gemacht
normalerweise weiß ja nein der markt
keine warmen tomaten aber egal probleme
zu fahren
ich kriege immer seiner warmen tomaten
normalerweise mag ich keine meinung zu
machen aber da shmeggs geliebt hast du
nicht wirklich ehrlich träumen der
bildungspolitik muss ich jetzt sage ich
jetzt was ist die krönung wäre jetzt
ganz schnell ich würde daher ist du
malst du mir schmeckt nicht genial
echt toll aber wenn alles nochmal
hackfleisch dann würde ich wirklich auf
die hauptspeise verzichten denn hier
kann es dann noch in den tipp nicht
sagen
[Musik]
unbekannt ist cool wenn du dich eher
okay diese vorspeise okay wenn es schon
die vorspeise hauptspeise ich werde ich
mich richtig bekannt ich mag es den so
pikanten ich muss glaube ich fairerweise
dazusagen denn das habe ich nicht
gemacht
fertiges produkt scatter quarks co
skipper okay das ist dan ruhe auf und
ich mach hauptspeisen also richtig gehen
ja die haben richtig gut geschmeckt ist
da kann man richtig gefallen bei den
mango das hat nicht ich wohl überrascht
wann wo und gurken ich glaub auf diese
geschmack wissen geschmack werde gar
nicht geschnitten ich genial und ich bin
total dafür
ich weiß nicht ich bringe sie war schon
ein paar italiener um ich meistens pro
skater heißt oder prosa ich weiß es
nicht aber es schmeckt einfach cool
gespannt auf die hausbank
als hauptgang habe ich mir überlegt
machen wir raps und zwar nehme ich hier
für die tiere ich habe das vegetarische
hackfleisch vegetarisches mühlberg sie
habe ich schmalz und zwar ist das
richtig cool da ist schon zwiebel mit
äpfel verfeinert das heißt ich spare mir
wahrscheinlich einfach die zwiebel
schneiderei wenn ich probiere es gleich
und dann merke ich auch mit der
geschmack reicht oder nicht
dann werde ich das ganze aber schon mit
tomatensaft und damit eine tomaten
rahmen so wird hier noch die koch creme
salz habe ich da und dann nehme ich den
grad lese und mit dem werde ich dann die
dort ihr sind backofen überbacken
dazu gibt dann süßkartoffel kommt nicht
nach zürich nehmen den weiß schimmelkäse
den weil ich mit dem spann zusammen als
dämpfer für zeigt verrückten ja im kopf
klingt gut jetzt gucken wir uns auch in
der praxis boot wird also zuerst einmal
werde ich jetzt direkt das mit dem
mühlentag machen also dabei hier jetzt
echt gespannt drauf wir haben gerade
einen freund bei uns der wohn für ein
paar tage bei uns und dass veganer und
es ist extrem schwierig mit einem
veganer zusammen zu leben wenn man
selbst nicht veganer ist also kann er
das auch gleich probieren später so rein
pflanzliches schmalz war das riecht gut
dass in röstzwiebeln drin
ich spare mir also das zwiebelschneiden
dann muss ich nicht drängen
wo also dass schmalzl zu zwei esslöffel
ich finde es ziemlich krass weil es
einfach wie hackfleisch aussieht und es
ist rein pflanzlich also wie gehabt so
und das schmeckt richtig gut des
richters hätte ich das jetzt schnell
vorankommt bisher mit rein das kurz
gucken wie lange das anbraten muss 4
minuten in der pfanne geht also ich bin
echt krass wird es aussieht sieht
wirklich aus wie hackfleisch und ich
finde es immer so ein thema manche sagen
ja wenn man veganer ist warum will man
dann überhaupt noch was was aussieht wie
fleisch aber es gibt ja einfach veganer
sie trotzdem wirklich ihr leben gerne
fleisch gegessen haben wegen dem
geschmack aber einfach vegan geworden
sind entweder wegen der gesundheit oder
eben gegen den tieren und dann finde ich
echt cool wenn es alternativen gibt die
rein pflanzlich sind aber trotzdem vom
geschmack her daran erinnern ich muss
das jetzt einmal probieren
schmeckt recht rot da kommt ihr drauf
das ist kein fleisch
niemals
[Musik]
so tomatensaft machen jetzt einfach mit
tomatensoße ich lieb' tomatensaft aber
ich glaube ihr kennt das auch ich
bestelle das hat immer wenn ich fliegt
dann trinke ich tomatensaft samira
übrigens auch die treter voll durch mit
tomaten ich hab die verpackung zerstört
aber immer nach der landung vergesse ich
tomatensaft zu kaufen
und ich mag es erst richtig farbe dafür
müssen wir einkaufen
[Musik]
120 alles vegan damit ablöschen 60 50
milliliter
jetzt gebe ich hier noch salz dazu
oregano und chili und etwas pfeffer
ich bin die einzige die so verpackungen
immer noch nie auf einem pferd also bot
hier sind glutenfrei hat es noch schön
handlich
ein bisschen davon und so seite zu
darmstadt
ich habe schon alle gedacht wie macht
sie das jetzt ich habe kurz an umdrehen
gedacht aber sein stock
[Musik]
selbst nach hause fährt denkt der murat
swr hackfleisch
[Musik]
so das sieht richtig gut aus ich gucke
war im kühlschrank vielleicht hab ich
noch allerdings schlechte nachricht ich
habe keine attrappen und keinmal und
keine wohnung konnte sich tex mex
burritos machen können schade aber wenn
ihr die zu hause habe auf jeden fall mit
rein ich scheiße jetzt einfach unter dem
wieder verschließbaren mich jetzt
komplett aufbrauchen also grad-rakete
drüber so ganz schön im backofen
[Musik]
diese jetzt gut vorbereitet ich gebe es
aber erst in den backofen wenn ich die
süßkartoffel chips gemacht habt also ich
hier kurz stehen lassen nämlich hier die
süßkartoffel die habe ich schon
gewaschen und braucht sie nicht schälen
und west jetzt einfach fein hobeln
[Musik]
und die werde ich jetzt einfach in der
friteuse zu bereiten
das wetter habe ich schon heft auf 170
grad und dann schön knusprig frittieren
die kommen da rein die in den backofen
und jetzt kann ich hier noch den djp
hier finde mich jetzt in weiß
schimmelkäse orders schön cremig man
lebt die hälfte dann schwand auch die
hälfte
erst kurze zeit zurück
der biss noch verfeinern mit etwas
zitronensaft und etwas honig
[Musik]
erst als brunner sagt
sv
[Musik]
sollten jetzt richtig schön unter dem
grill gratinieren die süßkartoffel chips
sind fertig hier gebe ich hier rein
ich habe jetzt nicht alle gemacht hat
nicht so viel salzen und pfeffern und
ich glaube hier kommt das grobkörnige
salz auch ziemlich politik des sprechers
zu reißen
bis 10 paprika edelsüß für die farbe
gehört auch schon wichtig sein
ich glaube das schmeckt ihm gut
beim tipp weiß ich besser ich weiß nicht
ob er aus schmeckt was es ist gespannt
was schönes lesetipp und ein brite schön
augen der kommt dann niemals drauf
[Musik]
komm wir machen einen kleinen farbtupfer
drauf
eine hauptspeise okay es kartoffelchips
ein dip und ein brite ok und hier schon
samstag passt doch alles zusammen oder
ist es was die sauber kriegen sowie
einfach um erstmal ein bisschen hier
eine spannung
[Musik]
ich glaube wenn ich dir sage was der
stimmung ist besser weiß schon über grad
sein schlimmstes riesig und morgen
roger ist das schaf rhein gelangt der
maske vor
also ich glaube der typ ist klasse
da war es ein bisschen weniger als
sonnen wirklich mal nur farbtöpfen sie
bewusst nicht verstecken kein käse auf
dem urlaub machen ich mache die kirche
tragen so schnell davon
ich bin gespannt ich wollte eigentlich
noch alle drei machen aber wir hatten
keine schießt das tor
da hatte ein bisschen den vogel zu an
gewackelt das seien ja nicht stimmen
auch ein gar nicht oder zu spät wissen
konnte
das war veganes mühlen hat er jetzt
nicht existierendes jetzt mir nicht
gesagt hättest jetzt hätte ich niemals
los das ist vegetarisch vegan ist
vegetarisch
das hat vielleicht schmeckt sagt möchte
egal ich bin mir ganz ganz sicher
versprochen
da kommt keiner braucht okay ist weiter
oder ich mach nachtisch
also ich bin mir zu 100 prozent sicher
dass nicht mal ein metzger drauf kommen
würde dass das kein fleisch isst kann
mir gut vorstellen weil die haben wir
haben wir das gemacht
kommen wir zum finale jetzt gibt es das
des herrn
ich habe ich mir jetzt überlegt weil ich
ja noch den kürbis übrig habe und ich
liebe kürbiskuchen könnte mal auf einem
kanal schauen da gibt es auch schon
kürbiskuchen rezepte machen wir kürbis
cupcakes als auch wenn ich den kürbis
für den teig ich komme gleich auch noch
der konsistenz her püriert oder einfach
nur zu drücken
ganz nämlich als mutterersatz und
business jahr streicht hat also muss man
sich mal wahr machen vorher cisco da
habe ich ja dabei macht einfach einen
ganz normalen rührteig dann habe ich
hier noch kürbiskerne die verdi
karamellisieren und so ein bisschen
obendrauf geben als crunchy und mit
philadelphia weil da mehr zu recht gut
geschmeckt hat da machen wir einfach ein
bisschen obst salat wieder drauf und ich
glaube das wird ein cooles der von murat
er mag zwar kein kürbis gerne essen
aber ich glaube im cup epec darunter
schmeckt sehr gut also zuerst einmal
butter also grunge und zucker cremig
gerührt
[Musik]
ist ja okay dann ein bisschen salz und
cremig rühren
also cremig rühren geht ziemlich schnell
klar mich einfach total streichfähig
jetzt die eier einzeln dazu und da an
bin ich schon gespannt darauf
also entweder ist es weiß und ich kann
ihn zu drücken oder essen und das muss
sagen finde ich jetzt ziemlich cool ich
habe auch kürbis aus der dose noch nie
gesehen bei uns ich kenne es aus amerika
da gibt's auch kürbis püree zum beispiel
und es ist halt cool für alle die jetzt
sagen ein riesengroßer kürbis den essig
niemals und so hat man das einfach
vorportionierten 265 gramm wenn ich auch
ne coole menge und vor allen dingen muss
man den kürbis nicht stehlen und nicht
schneiden weil das ist glaube ich aber
dass mühsam ist am kürbis
man hat nichts übrig und kann ihnen das
ganze jahr über bekommen also nicht nur
zur kürbiszeit weil dosen produkte
werden ja immer erntefrisch dann in die
dosen gegeben und konserviert jetzt
probieren
[Musik]
schmeckt bisschen wie im türkischen
gibt's ein kürbis dass er das nennt sich
charakter so schmeckt sowie das bisschen
feierlich und das passt echt gut
hier steht zwar ideal für super oder
püree aber ich suche für das süße passt
aber ich werde jetzt einmal uns vorher
probieren
das ist übrigens ein butternut kürbis
und da sind als zutaten drin butternut
kürbis wasser zucker salz und
zitronensäure als säuerungsmittel das
heißt man kann im prinzip die
flüssigkeit wenn man jetzt nur suppe
kocht auch einfach mit rein schritten
muss man nicht wegschicken nicht
wegklicken
aber ich nehme es mal nur das hier und
der button hat kürbis ist auch ein
kürbis thema auf jeden fall fehlen muss
also dass ich nicht wie beim hokkaido
dass man dafür die schale mit verwendet
sondern erspart man sich nicht das
schiff jetzt bisschen zu drücken
dann zum mittag und kürbis passt immer
zählt ganz gut
backpulver und nähen und dann nur noch
ab
[Musik]
es sieht aus wie ein ganz normaler
übertreibung also da kommen noch nicht
drauf das service team steht
[Musik]
ab in den backofen
während die massen sitzen noch backen
kann ich schon mal die kürbiskerne
karamellisieren
das heißt einfach ein bisschen zucker in
die pfanne am besten eine beschichtete
pfanne und dann ganz langsam schmelzen
lassen
[Musik]
und dann mache ich jetzt damit dem rat
auch noch was gesunde so leckeres
bekommt unseres frisches bekommt ein
richtig cooler obstsalat
das heißt sie habe ich jetzt schon ein
bisschen trauben kleingeschnitten
mandarinen glaube also alles was ihr da
habt könnt ihr bereits benutzten dann
ein bisschen vanille extrakten schuss
zitronensaft dazu noch eine banane dazu
geben und das ganze dann mit den
cottagers servieren
[Musik]
wisst ihr wie affen die banane schält
ohne metern aber so weit dann hat man
zum schluss lok und der stängel
[Musik]
immer ein auge auf den zucker haben
zucker immer schön aufpassen dass er
nicht verbrennt und hat alles
geschmolzen ist es richtig jetzt schon
richtig lecker macht karamell dann
kürbiskerne dazu und einfach so ein
bisschen schwenken bisschen schön farbe
bekommen und alles schön mit dem
karamell ummantelt ist
[Musik]
und hier kommt jetzt noch das topping
für die muffins und zwar nehme ich da
den rest vom brand da habe ich noch was
übrig habt ihr puderzucker und die
mandarine und es war ruhig jetzt alles
und es kommt glaube ich richtig gut
[Musik]
so sehen die kürbiskerne richtig gut aus
jetzt muss man auch echt aufpassen dass
sie nicht verbrennen und englisch
verrückt aber ich glaub da passt einfach
ein schuss balsamico dazu ich brauche
jetzt einfach farbe geschmack ich glaube
es wird gut
[Musik]
was jetzt kurz einkochen und dann
abkühlen man könne man nämlich die
muffins direkt nach dem backen und nach
dem abkühlen fertigstellen
[Musik]
zeit wird's bisher ich glaube den muffin
den teppich aus
[Musik]
so dann hätte ich genauso
wenn hier der krampf angespannt
echt gut
nach gutem am samstag
[Musik]
da cottage cheese
ich glaube dass dieser cottage cheese
ziemlich cool dazu passt denn wer mit
den süßen kürbis machen dann die glasur
dann den crash jetzt ein bisschen hart
stieß ich hasse das herzchen damit die
frei von mir so was springen sie es
gerne frühstücke ist keiner frischkäse
gurken in scheiben hobeln salz und
pfeffer drüber unterrichts flecker
könnte mit dem auch machen
[Musik]
fertig beim dass er selbst erst mal ganz
cool ich muss ich sagen das ist sowohl
als hingerichtet habe ich ja eigentlich
hingerichtet haben recht es ist wichtig
mal hingelegt ich weiß noch wie das wort
kennt das ist bitter wenig bis keine
café keese genau köln herrscht aber er
setzt sich auch unser mit gewürzen zu
machen ihn kenne ich also keine neuen
viel probiert es war aus einer karte
käse und der obstsalat zusammen aber
schon mal dass bürger leidet kann schon
mal herzhaft und genau das ist so und
das war ja auch das was ich gemacht habe
auch am anfang mit dem mango joghurt er
wollte einfach die produkte ich wollte
nicht süß zu süß und salzig zu salzig
sondern ich habe alles gemanagt so wie
es keiner erwartet
alles andere wäre ja wie gesagt der
fischerkönige frisch krise setzt nicht
auf und nicht gekommen bin ja so süß und
zahlt sich schon in dem kohl es
frühstück frischkäse und dann ob es
danach viermal den machen okay
ich sag dir nicht was drin steckt also
das heißt das produkt steckt drin
richtig und es ist kaufe darunter nur
schicks drin drin und obendrauf
also unsere ordner hasst man ja ist noch
weit weg war steinig ehrliches
kürbiskerne oder aus den kürbiskernen
mangeln gemacht - ist cool was aus
kürbiskernen mangeln immer wie sie das
kürbis kleine peak günstiger sind als
man das gefühl jetzt bei den nachbarn
ich bin gespannt wie du denn machen das
richtig so sagt bad ragaz kürbis
schmeckt viel besser als jemand ja
normal sind wie kürbisse weil ich wette
wenn ich hoffe die talking heads erkannt
an der farbe aber beim button hat und
ich denke noch nicht und sieht man was
ich noch machen könne
hartmann dagegen geht es nicht um
gespritzt aber auch orangen wenn ihr
ungespritzte orangen nehmen dann können
auch noch für die testen oben drauf
machen
normalerweise sagt mir lieber ins essen
als mit kürbis reizen kann aber das ist
richtig cool also jetzt mal ganz großen
respekt das sind drei mahlzeiten gewesen
jetzt hast du gemacht hat er mit 16
produkten 17 17 produkten 17 produkte
irgendwo in drei gängen zu machen ist
echte kunden und dann so raffiniert zu
verpacken
das ist nicht langweilig wird wenn ja
würde ich sagen ich hab die challenge
gewonnen
100% schönes gewonnen das heißt für mich
ich habe jetzt feierabend und murat auf
die küche aufräumen
es wird jedes gerichts wonach kochen
oder irgendwas anders machen fühlt sie
noch gar nicht brauchen aber ich würde
mal ist
du hast du gehst rein gemacht das war ja
ich finde es kam öfter machen macht den
warenkorb und dann überlege ich noch da
entstehen nämlich die kreativsten
rezepte bereit ihre rezepte nach machen
wollte und sie sind es wird vermutet
dass man sich am besten vorspeise
hauptspeise so rückblickend oder war es
nicht vergleichbar
ich kann mich gar nicht mehr an alles
erinnern macht am besten alle drei
rezepte nach die rezepte findet ihr auf
station ist blog de oder auch bei brad
balkone gut
ich fand die challenge an cool weil für
mich war es etwas aufregung ist man
normalerweise hat irgendwie so
irgendeine idee schon hast du machen
willst und jetzt hatte ich auch produkte
und habe mir dann mit für die
lebensmittel rezepte gelegt und dann
wurde es richtig ist die folge
dann schreibt gerne kommentar warum soll
ja vielleicht mal was richtig gemacht
hin
ich glaube ich alle alles wieder in eine
schüssel um schüssel gemacht und zu
sagen
also viel spaß beim nachmachen und ihren
spaß und welche schlecht ist ja
[Musik]